هل قصر جو بايدن مع اسرائيل منذ بدايه
حربها الاخيره بالعكس كان سخيا بالدعم
المريح والغزل الصريح واعلن منذ عقود انه
صهيوني ولم يخفي حبه العذريه لنتنياهو
بيبي اي لاف يو يقول له ومع ذلك تجد وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير
ينتقده في الصحافه العالميه يقول لك اداره
بايدن تعرقل المجهود الحريه الاسرائيليه
ولو فاز ترامب ف سيمنح اسرائيل يدا اطول
للقضاء على حماس هذه التصريحات هذا الكلام
احرج نتنياهو تصريحات مخجله بحق الرجل
الكريم مع اسرائيل استمعوا لما قاله
نتنياهو
اسرا اسرائيل دوله ذات سياده نحن نقدر
بشده الدعم الذي تلقيناه من اداره بايدن
منذ اندلاع الحرب دعم التسليح ودعم
المؤسسات الدوليه وارسال قوات الى المنطقه
وغيرها وهذا لا يعني انه ليس بيننا
اختلافات في الراي ولكن حتى اليوم تمكنا
من
تجاوزها لماذا لم يرضى بن غفير عن اداء
بايدن مع انه ارسل حاملات الطائرات للشرق
الاوسط وفتح جسرا عسكريا جويا من امريكا
لاسرائيل اوصل من خلاله 200 طائره مشحونه
باحدث العتاد اكثر من 10000 طن من الاسلحه
وصلت لاسرائيل وخصص مساعدات عسكريه اضافيه
بقيمه 14 مليار دولار لماذا يفضل بن غفير
ترامب هل لانه مثلا اعترف بالقدس عاصمه
لاسرائيل نقل سفارته اليها جوع فلسطينيين
بقطع مساعداتهم شرعن الاستيطان المجرم
دوليا عدا انه اعترف بسياده اسرائيل على
الجولان المحتل
بالمختصر ترامب اضر بالفلسطينيين اكثر مما
افاد اسرائيل الهذا السبب يفضله بن غفير
تغريدات كثيره على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ماجد ابو دياك يقول لك لا اظن
ان ترامب سيكون اكثر صيانه من بايدن
وبلينك ومع ذلك يرغب نتنياهو بمقاومه ضغوط
بايدن للتسابق مع خطه ما بعد الحرب
والدوله الفلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح التي
يريد بها شراء التطبيع مع العرب بثمن بخس
رش تقول بالعكس لو كان ترامب رئيسا لما
تمادى نتنياهو لهذه الدرجه لان ترامب يريد
مصلحته الماديه يحب المال لن يعطيه شيئا
بسهوله سمير قال ترامب وبايدن الاثنان
متصهين ويخضعان للوبي الصهيوني والحزبين
الرئيسيان في امريكا متفقان على دعم
اسرائيل بلا حدود اوديسي تقول لقد قلت
دائما ان الديمقراطيين خونه بايدن المنهك
يديره اوباما الخائن اوافق على انه مع
وجود ترامب في السلطه ستحضى اسرائيل بكل
الدعم اخر تغريده من رشيد يقول اي رئيس
حكومه كان سيطرد بن غفير فورا لان
تصريحاته مضره جدا بحكومته ولكن نتنياهو
مستعد للبقاء في السلطه باي طريقه ولو على
حساب تدمير العلاقات مع اسرائيل تصريحات
بن غفير اغضبت زعيم المعارضه يا اير لابيد
يقول لك بن غفير اثبت انه لا يفهم شيئا في
السياسه الخارجيه ونتنياهو ليس لديه سيطره
على المتطرفين في حكومته